لم يعد أنطون في الخطوط الأمامية
يروي كيف انتهى به المطاف إلى أسير
حرب في روسيا ، لقد كان خلف القضبان
للمرة الثالثة بسبب المخدرات
عندما وضعوني في السجن ، سمعت أنهم
كانوا يجندون الخدمة لمدة ستة أشهر وقد أصدروا
عفواً كما أخبرني
لذلك قام بالتسجيل مع وحدة
من المدانين الملحقة
بوزارة الدفاع الروسية ، بعد أسبوعين فقط من
التدريب الأساسي ، تم نقله إلى
الخطوط الأمامية بالقرب من باكموت
بعد أيام من القصف المكثف دون طعام
ولم يسمع سوى مياه الأمطار للشرب.
القوات الأوكرانية خارج جحره
الذي افترض أنه سيُعدموه
اعتقدت أن هذه هي النهاية التي يتذكرها أنني قمت
بتحويل بندقيتي إلى وضع اللقطة الواحدة
واعتقدت أنني سأطلق النار على نفسي ولكني
لم أستطع أن
أغير
هذا الفيديو الذي صوره جنود من
عروض لواء الهجوم الأوكراني الثالث  في
اللحظات المتوترة عندما استسلم أنطون ورفيقه سلافا ،
أخبرتهم القوات الأوكرانية
على عكس الروس أننا لا نقتل
سجناء
تحدثنا إلى أنطون سلاف وجندي آخر
في سجن مؤقت في شرق
أوكرانيا يخفون وجوههم ولا
يستخدموا أسمائهم الحقيقية.الهجوم
الثالث  سمح لنا اللواء
بالوصول إلى الأسرى وكان اثنان من
جنودهم في الغرفة لإجراء
المقابلات ، وسيتم نقل الأسرى قريبًا
إلى المخابرات الأوكرانية التي
لا يبدو أنهم تحت الإكراه
ووافقوا على مشاركة قصصهم ، كما
قال سلافا إنه يقضي وقتًا بسبب المخدرات.
كان الطعام شحيحًا في الخنادق ، ولم يكن لدينا
مجموعات طبية ، كما يقول ، قال
قادته أخذوا جميع المسكنات
للارتفاع الذي يتذكره ،
ونتيجة لذلك ، كانت المعنويات الصادرة غير منطقية
فظيعة
[موسيقى]
أصيب سيرجي بقنبلة يدوية قبل
الاستسلام  القوات الأوكرانية كان
جنديًا متعاقدًا وليس مدانًا ،
أكمل عقده لمدة ستة أشهر في
هيرزون وعاد إلى المنزل ، لكن عندما
تردد في توقيع عقد آخر ،
أعطاه المدعي العسكري
سجنًا اختياريًا أو عاد إلى الجبهة ، انتهى به الأمر
خارج باهاموت بشكل دائم
انهار الانضباط في الحريق الأوكراني ،
فر الضباط من جميع الأوهام تحطمت ،
كان الأمر مختلفًا تمامًا عما رأيته على
التلفزيون ، وهناك حقيقة موازية تقول إن المدينة شعرت
بالخوف والألم وخيبة الأمل لدى قادتي ، حيث
فرض قانون صدر العام الماضي في روسيا
أحكامًا بالسجن من 3 إلى 10 سنوات.  الجنود
الذين يستسلمون طواعية إذا عاد إلى
منزله في عملية تبادل أسرى ، قد
ينتهي الأمر بأن يعود أنطون مرة أخرى إلى سجن روسي